hello everyone i hope that you're doing
well
and thanks for joining us it's my great
pleasure to introduce dr
cindy whitten who is a wonderful
colleague friend and a human being
latin earned her phd in history at uc
berkeley and specializes in the history
of vietnam
southeast asian print culture and
libraries
currently she is a postdoctoral fellow
in international humanities
in the department of history and the
kogut institute for humanities at brown
university
where she teaches innovative virtual
reality based
courses on southeast asian history in
her book
manuscript reading and misreading the
social life of libraries
in colonial and colonial control in
vietnam 1865 to 1958
examines the cultural and political
history of libraries in hanoi and saigon
from the french colonial period through
to the decolonization of libraries
through the lens of cultural imperialism
national legitimacy and social practices
of public reading she has presented her
scholarship
internationally including um in the u.s
vietnam and singapore
and her essay the social life of the
hanoi central library
reading cultures in public space 1919 to
1941
wandan association for asian studies
patana
kitiarsa southeast asian council prize
in 2020.
in addition to being a scholar dr wilton
is also a digital humanist
an artist a poet a translator a
filmmaker
a publisher a feminist and a refugee
she seamlessly weaves her these
dimensions
into provocative and beautiful
multimedia work including short films
that meditate on intergenerational
transmissions
of language love and loss dr nguyen is
currently working on a poetic
documentary film on language
on the language of vietnamese refugee
remembrance and history
and since this brief introduction does
not do justice to the breadth and depth
of dr nguyen's intellectual and creative
endeavors
please do visit her website and i'll
drop those in the chat for you
for more information and access to her
wonderful work
today dr winton's talk is titled the
politics of good reading
libraries and the public in lake
colonial vietnam
please join me in welcome being dr
nguyen
thank you so much for the introduction
it's truly an honor to be introduced by
glenn who
um is is really
just makes me remember all the different
types of collaborative work that we've
done together and really to just to
celebrate the different types of
things that i've done in terms of my
pedagogy and research so thank you again
glenn
um i want to also take this opportunity
to thank you glenn eric and chris for
inviting me to be part of this brownback
series
i truly appreciate this opportunity to
be in virtual
intellectual community with all of you
and to share this work in progress
i very much look forward to the q a to
elaborate on this work as well as a
larger book manuscript
so i'm just going to take a second to
set up share screen
and not multitask while doing this to
make sure everything's
good so again thank you for this
opportunity i'm cindy nguyen a cultural
historian of vietnam
libraries and print culture today's talk
i will first discuss the main research
questions and interventions of my book
manuscript titled this reading
i'll share an excerpt from the book
focus on the case study of the 1930s and
1940s book wagons biblioboost project
and coaching china southern vietnam
and i'll conclude with a discussion on
the book's chapters scope and major
contributions to the field
so my book project title in this reading
examines the cultural and political
history of libraries and print control
in vietnam from 1865 to 1958.
i analyzed the changing mission of
colonial libraries the hybrid of state
documentation
and a public space for self-directed
education and social life
focused primarily on the state central
library in hanoi
and the coach in china library in saigon
shown here in this slide
this book advances a two-part argument
on the history of libraries and current
control in indochina
which today consists of vietnam cambodia
laos first to build libraries is to
build the state
libraries legitimize the authority of
the state as infrastructures of symbolic
modernity
print control and documentary heritage
second
library users also shape the everyday
mission and social function of the
library beyond these hegemonic
aspirations of colonial
and post-colonial states this study
demonstrates how builders and users
articulated in meeting of public through
the functions of the coneos state
libraries to serve its readers
to preserve documentary heritage and to
operate as a broader instrument of
public education
and moralization this two-part argument
reveals the significance of the library
as an institution of state building
print control and public reading culture
the this book is the first comprehensive
history of the library in southeast asia
the narrative is bookended by two
formative events the founding of the
coach in china french colonial library
in 1865
which was the first colonial state
public library in indochina
and the centralization of the national
library of the new republic of vietnam
in 1958 south vietnam so this chronology
challenge is externally defined
chronologies such as 1945 world war
ii 1954 the end of the first indochina
war
and completely offers this new frame of
reference and understanding into
processes of colonization and
decolonization
and creation of post-colonial
nation-states from the perspective of
vietnam
in terms of source material i primarily
use newspapers official archives reader
statistics in vietnam and france
i topped down and bottom-up analysis of
library builders and users
contributes to the findings of the
colonial state libraries public and
urban
space knowledge curation and print
culture with attention to labor access
in space
the book sheds sight on the politics of
gender and race and libraries
as well as its legacies in
post-colonization building in vietnam
so as a way to illuminate the arguments
of the book manuscript i will focus on
the specific
case study of the mobile library wagon
project and coaching china south vietnam
in 1930s to 1940s
on march 1936 the first biblio bus
or mobile library book wagon in
indochina began its journey through
nine provinces and coaching china the
library wagon circulated 832
french and vietnamese books of popular
literature politics morality and science
from the coaching china saigon library
every two months the book wagon toured
through the nine provinces
lending books to vietnamese and french
readers a vietnamese driver and
secretary from the coaching china
library
accompanied the wagon the book wagon
encountered many delays in accidents for
example on september 1st
1937 on the way from basia to bien hua
the book wagon struck a tree stump when
swerving to avoid hitting a
seven-year-old girl who was in the road
the accident severely damaged the wagon
delaying the trip for one month while
the vehicle underwent extensive repairs
the bibliobus book wagon continued its
route on november 15th
1937 from saigon through the western
mekong delta region following this
schedule
so in this schedule here you see that
this is the first mobile
book wagon after its repairs departing
from saigon
note the limited operating hours of the
mobile wagon at each stop
as well as a central location in front
of administrative offices
schools and hospitals over the course of
a year the mobile
book wagon served a total of 10 000
readers
due to the success of the first book
circuit on december 1937
a second mobile book wagon traveled
through eight other provinces of
coaching china
back leo gammo
the second mobile wagon served a total
of 21
500 readers over the course of one year
the story of the mobile book wagon seems
particularly
ambitious and curious why did the
governmental and public coaching china
library circulate its valuable
collections to the countryside
what books moved from the urban center
of saigon to the provinces
who were the readers and what did they
check out a closer examination of this
peculiar project
sheds light on the geographic and
symbolic extension of the colonial state
into the countryside
through physically bringing quote good
reading to the people
good reading i argue was a changing
political
moral and literary concept advanced by
french and vietnamese government
administrators librarians publishers
writers as well as readers this talk
offers three discoveries
first it reveals how high-level
administrators and the indochina library
director advanced
a cultural propaganda project to
disseminate good reading
as didactic politically safe and
vulgarizing reading matter to the
countryside through book wagons
secondly i show how the state-initiated
book wagons project
intersected with the development of
vietnamese reading public
actively enmeshed in global translated
literature in french and vietnamese
as well as a growing body of a romanized
script
vietnamese literature thirdly i reveal a
vibrant vietnamese public sphere who
debated the role of good reading
and called for the development of gup-mu
library collections for the larger
vietnamese public
my primary research question is the
following what role did the official
state library such as the coaching china
library
and then also the hanoi center library
play within this larger landscape of
print culture and reading public in the
late colonial period
this talk on the biblio bus mobile wagon
project as well as a larger book
manuscript
points to the mechanics the discourse
and everyday practice of the library to
fulfill its role
as an official government institution a
resource of public education
and a cultural space for the practice of
collective responsibility
urban civility and public reading
from 1928 to 1930 the french colonial
administration drew
inspiration from the existing valley
pustaka state
sponsored publishing barrel distribution
office and library system
in the dutch east indies today indonesia
governor general of indochina pia
pasquier commissioned extensive studies
on the duchy's indies publishing and
popular libraries project seeking to
implement a similar project in french
indochina
emil variak the director of the office
of indigenous publishing
and the resident superior at the
resident superior of tonkin
north vietnam he studied the bali
busakha in indonesia and evaluated the
current state of publishing and print in
indochina
iraq argued that vietnamese publications
perpetuated dangerous criticisms of
french colonization
and civilization he quotes vietnamese
literary production is struggling and
anarchy and drags itself
into insignificance apart from some
republications of old poems or ancient
moral guides
a small number of serious works the
majority of vietnamese print
criticizes us the french and speaks
poorly of our civilization
praising the duchy's indeeds vayrock
argued that the valley pustaka created
libraries and schools police stations
hospitals
and instituted an office of publishing
which produced and distributed good
reading throughout the country
colonial administrators such as iraq
were keenly aware and threatened by the
rise and influence
of anti-colonial sentiment and political
organizing into china
in the 20s and the 30s in his essay the
program for the recovery of the public
spirit
from his report bayrack elaborated on
the colonial administration's anxieties
over vietnamese radicalism
iraq described the existing threat of
revolutionary political ideas chinese
influence anti-french sentiment among a
growing generation of dangerous young
urban vietnamese radicals eager for
change
as seen in this slide iraq called
attention to the pervasiveness of
bolshevik and anti-french agitation
amongst urban vietnamese especially
students workers youth
the spirit of subversion undermined the
vietnamese family corrupted the minds of
young students
and could potentially permeate into the
country's side
within this context of increased
radicalism
the colonial administration developed
new strategies to control the quickly
spreading evil
insubordination amongst outspoken
vietnamese
iraq believed that carefully crafted and
widespread propaganda messages could
counter the rising political anti-french
and revolutionary sentiment in the
vietnamese urban youth as seen in this
slide bayrack
created this indirect propaganda
strategy where he emphasized the
importance of the rural population
the group that he considered not only
the humble true people of indochina
but also the population most vulnerable
to the political ideologies propagated
by urban intellectuals
iraq suggested two effective methods of
indirect propaganda
propaganda through action and propaganda
by imagery and appearance
this essay concludes with an attached
list of european works to translate to
vietnamese
bayrak argued that the best work to
translate for vietnamese readers should
include french popular literature from
the middle ages such as tales of peru
lafontaine's fame fables renard's novels
moral and educational works as well as
proverbs
this list focused primarily on
instructional apolitical texts he called
that could civilize and morally uplift
vietnamese readers the colonial state
saw a direct political interest in
indigenous publishing and libraries
to produce and disseminate a
pro-colonial message iraq's study is
only one of the examples of extensive
documentation from the colonial
administration
that show how control of publishing in
libraries was essential as a propaganda
tool for the colonial state
at the same time of this process with
the bayrock
the director of the archives and
libraries paul buday
initiated efforts to create provincial
libraries a distribution network and
book wagons or video booths
through the existing infrastructure of
the state directorate library system
in hanoi and saigon i'll now discuss a
bit of contextual background the library
system in indochina and the role of paul
buday
the vision and organization of indochina
library was deeply shaped by the first
and only culinary era director pablo day
alba day graduated from the renowned
archives and library school in richard
in 1909
as an archivist paleographer on november
30th 1917
boude was appointed as director of the
newly centralized directorate
of archives and libraries in indochina
which which sorry in hanoi
so that was based in hanoi pablo de was
also the head director of the hanoi
central library opened in 1919 which
operated both
as an extension of the bibliotech nasty
now in france
and as an indochina state library in the
colonial capital of hanoi
papa day's standardized papade
standardized technical and
administrative policies for
documentation in indochina
most importantly buday defined the
function and mission of a modern library
based off of french libraries
he argued that encyclopedic libraries
must assemble the best works of all
levels of knowledge
an orderly stable and comprehensive
collections a modern library followed
french model of libraries he argued
specifically the bnf the bibliotheque
nasa now
to provide scientifically classified
best works to the greater public
bidet sought to implement these visions
to all the regional libraries in
indochina
the hanoi central library the coaching
china central library as well as the
phnom penh cambodia library
throughout the colonial period though
the vision and reality of the colonial
library as modern encyclopedic and
public
often differed in prince in in practice
many of these libraries such as the
coaching channel library in saigon
originated first as a government library
to provide documentation
reference matter and reading leisure for
french administrator and at times their
wives who had relocated to saigon
yet by 1920s and 1930s an increasing
number of vietnamese university students
commercial workers and researchers
sought to access these valuable library
collections
furthermore library administrators
debated what type of good reading should
be added
to the library collection libraries
encountered budget constraints to build
collections and hire
staff they also ran out often ran out of
space for storage and offered a limited
number of seats in the reading room as
pictured here in the coaching china
library
which was housed in the government
secretariat building together with the
archives coach in china
in 1938 the reading room held a
collection of 36 000 volumes
although constrained by a limited number
of 44 seats the reading room was
able to welcome over 133 readers each
day
during 1938 the popular lending section
recorded a total of 31
000 borrowers and 55 000 book loans
since the founding of the director of
archives and libraries in 1917 boude had
envisioned an expansive network of
provincial libraries throughout
indochina
inspired also by the bali busta in
indonesia the governor general
pier piaske officially enlisted buday to
research public libraries and book
wagons around the world on march 28 1929
pablo dey wrote to the american library
association office in paris
and requested documents to study
american circulating book wagons and
shipment service
in order to develop a similar project in
vietnam bidet was particularly
interested in the practical
cost-efficient methods used by
automobiles
for the distribution of books from here
it begins an extensive exchange of
letters between boude and libraries from
all around the world
but they received extensive replies and
research resources from the ala the
american library association in paris
the office in chicago even the
california state library in sacramento
american library shipped hundreds of
recent pamphlets legal documents book
catalogs
newspapers for boude to study the
organization of circulating libraries
and book wagons in america
these resources explore topics such as
the curatorial responsibility of
librarians
the importance of literacy and access to
useful knowledge such as technology
to our technical books boude also wrote
to the metropolitan library in beijing
in china the central library in baroda
india
to request information on their
circulating libraries program
this points to the significant ways in
which models for library development was
a transnational process
not always stemming from metropole to
colony
from these comparative library models
boude proposed his circulating library
project which consisted the following
lending of french and romanized
vietnamese the popular script of spoken
vietnamese
books in the provinces and the
distribution of the provinces
to the provinces these books and
pamphlets published by indigenous
writers under official control
recognizing the high cost of this
project would emphasize the potential of
a circulating library system
to provide the european indigenous
population the provinces
a healthy leisure activity additionally
boude argued that the circulating
library project could combat the spread
of politically dangerous reading matter
among vietnamese readers such as works
inspired by bolshevik propaganda
pamphlets
widely distributed in china he says in
this slide
similar to veyrock's proposal for
counter propaganda initiatives bidet
argued that circulating libraries
could also combat the dangerous
influence of chinese regular
revolutionary texts
this counter-propaganda strategy sought
to increase the availability of safe
texts through state-sponsored
distribution libraries and publishing
in hopes that these texts would flood
the vietnamese print market
by making safe reading matter more
plentiful colonial administrators and
boude hope to compete with the
popularity of illicit reading matter
amongst vietnamese
throughout the 1930s the governor
general and local administration
continued to discuss debate revise
and implement aspects of the
comprehensive project to develop popular
libraries
an office of publishing as well as a
book wagons project
yet an entirely centralized and evenly
distributed system never materialized
throughout indochina
due to economic crises political
insurrections and a rapid turnover in
political administration
if the day continued to organize
circulating book wagons throughout the
30s and early 40s albeit with fiscal
limitations
here for example is a photograph of a
book wagon circulating secular and
buddhist texts from the royal library in
cambodia
that was organized by another scholar
administrator suzanne karpoliz
the curator of the buddhist institute
and royal library in cambodia through
the 1930s
um this book wagon pictured on the left
circulated thousands of volumes
throughout the
southeast cambodia southwest coaching
china region
in comparison the cambodge library
picture on the right was functioned more
as the administrative archive and
reference library
the directorate continued to organize
these circulating libraries
sporadically in the 40s especially
throughout south vietnam
coaching china region a 1946 report
argued that
circulating libraries brought french
culture to the outer isolated regions of
coaching china
which served as a healthy leisure
activity the report estimated that
throughout 36 to 46
the circulating libraries brought more
than 23 000 books to the provinces
in 1942 just to zoom in a little bit
more
to get a sense of the readers and the
reader tastes
over 20 in over 22 provinces as far as
participated in the circulating library
project based out of the saigon coaching
china library
for example the august 1942 borrowing
list from the port province of zach zach
recorded 31 total borrowers for the
month of which two were french men one
one is
a vietnamese woman and the remaining 28
readers were beating these men
most of the books borrowed were french
popular novels such as pop fiction
on romance police stories espionage by
delhi
translations of popular world literature
like the work of agatha christie
pearl s buck and leo tolstoy as well as
french language historical works on
napoleon
caesar books on science and geography in
terms of
vietnamese language works the materials
checked out were in structural texts as
well as new popular vietnamese novels
as seen in this slide these book wagon
numbers
point to what peter zimmerman has termed
as a provincial cosmopolitanism
a popular global and french literature
network in vietnam
and my research adds to this analysis by
highlighting the logistical movement of
these texts into the countryside
furthermore the book wagon circulated
the circulation records show how the
booming
vietnamese blueprint market of new
popular literature
such as those by vietnamese southern
writer of hobo chan
my research on the biblio bus reveals
how these new experimental forms of
looking literature primarily produced in
the urban centers of hanoi cyclone
extended geographically moving and
conceptualizing the vietnamese reading
public
into the countryside another major
argument that i advance
is that the development of libraries was
not simply a french initiated project
but
involved a larger community of
vietnamese publishers journalists
and literary figures who called for the
development of libraries for the larger
vietnamese language reading public
in 1942 cuomov drafted an extensive
program to create a gup-nu library
system throughout the three regions of
vietnam
and published this four-page essay
featured prominently in the popular
colonial periodical
was the pen name of saigon-based
journalist and writer lee vin kuhn
who had worked in the saigon library in
the 40s as well as
participated in associations for the
advancements of goku
in his essay he directly draws a
connection between the development of
new libraries and the advancement of
vietnamese civilization and collective
identity
the first part of the essay establishes
the pervasiveness of goku
and the patriotic responsibility of each
person in the country to serve and
improve the language since it directly
connects to the progress of the
motherland he
quotes taking a closer analysis of his
essay
as shown in this quote viet points to
the importance of spreading gulfmoon
works in a larger collective and uses a
tone emphasizing the urgent necessity to
think beyond the individual
and towards the collective be it frame
the library's project as a collective
duty
he says i have been able to
superfluously enjoy these priceless
spiritual nourishments i must not be
selfish and only enjoy these
works for myself i must do something so
that my compatriots less fortunate than
i
who do not have money to even witness
and see these valuable works of guru
can benefit from these books along with
me
at the foundation of this project kung
viet outlines a collective
concept of the vietnamese public tied
deeply to the dutiful involvement of the
collective public or the guancho
for the mass general benefit regardless
of class religion and politics
the author subtly critiques existing
libraries in indochina stating that
private libraries of associations
only permitted access to its members
while the state hanoi central library
made it difficult to
enter and access it's called new
collection viet described his proposed
project as a
library network with central libraries
first in hanoi saigon
way bridging into provincial libraries
and then a book wagon
bringing books to provinces and villages
furthermore
it argues that the preservation of women
books are part of a project to preserve
vietnamese culture
in analyzing this important essay i
point to the relationship between
individual and collective
duty and how it intersects with the
consciousness of the public
and a sense of vietnamese collective
evolution as seen on the bottom of the
slide
furthermore via's argument and word
choice emphasizes how the public work of
building a library could also contribute
to a broader cultural and national
project
of defining and preserving a sense of
vietnamese culture through
new collections we have proposed a
certain library or book wagons
initiative which would bring book new
books and newspapers directly to distant
villages and hamlets
viet described this as a good
popularization effort
to bring the villager useful knowledge
for the betterment of their lives
it's not surprising that the proposed
project mirrors that of the existing
directorate system
and the proposals from boude given via
experience working in the saigon library
yet so a lot of his model his proposed
system was modeled off of the existing
state hanoi and saigon libraries
yet the proposed system distinguished
itself from the state libraries due to
its emphasis firstly on google
collections
and secondly on the collective monetary
investment from the wider vietnamese
public
furthermore it points to the cultural
capital of the library
as an appealing gathering place for the
ultimate literary culture
of vietnamese educated youth writers
thinkers and elite readers
this project is significant because it
points to how the creation of public
library was at its foundation a
collective endeavor
tied to vietnamese national community
and responsibility of compatriots to
cultivate
protect and share that identity
according to viet
about a week after viet's article the
journalist and scholar of literature in
history um
expanded confidence proposal to include
building reading societies in the
countryside
also published in cheetah in the article
the city outskirts and the countryside
need these reading societies
explained that existing library
initiatives only serve a limited
minority of urban readers
literate and french the author also
criticizes the hanoi central library as
restrictive given its linguistic focus
on french material
and thus limiting its influence to only
a few and failing to provide a universal
service to all
building upon viet's linguistic demands
from work with blue libraries
also calls for development of these
reading spaces beyond the urban confines
and into the rural outskirts and
countryside communities
specifically huabang argues that
cultivating reading practices had a
moralizing benefit
and thus should be universally applied
across geographic reaches
first thing you notice is how how the
creation of libraries supported good
leisure and thus could offset
bad leisure behaviors besides the
promotion of healthy leisure activities
among emphasis that a reading tastes
must be cultivated
for the good of humanity you can see
this in the quote here where he
discusses reading books as an antidote
to bad leisure practices
such as going to taverns building upon
the metaphor of reading as eating
represents books as desirable food
objects with attractive sense and
spiritual nourishment in the second
quote here in this slide
he notes how urban readers already have
a certain addiction to this type of
literary consumption
proposed that reading societies could be
built in the existing temples of
literature and shrines in the villages
the hamlets
he draws heavily from confucian values
of scholarship and examination
to argue that the inherent value of
literature and reading
honored through the creation of these
reading societies
quoting a popular aphorism among exam
laureates that translate says
even if a child is stupid they must
still try to study and read literature
declares how proposed reading societies
carry on the wishes of vietnamese
scholarly
ancestors similar to viet's proposal
bang concludes this essay with a
statement that the guppy library project
ultimately benefits the public the
people the zhanjun
he calls for the individual districts to
sacrifice fifty percent of their budget
used for festivals
to contribute to the developing of these
library projects
the biblio book wagons project is
significant because firstly it situates
the library within
the landscape of print culture and
geography of colonial control
and secondly it points to the
administrative exchanges between
imperial projects and international
library sciences
i reveal the differ diffuse negotiations
and fragmented implementation
of an official system to control the
publishing and distribution of print
through indochina
motivated by indirect propaganda these
projects to centralize print control
emerge out of colonial fears of rising
urban and
radicalism as well as anti-colonial
revolutionary ideologies
in comparison director of the archives
and libraries paul buday focused on
expanding access to
quote a political reading matter for the
countryside through circulating book
wagons
but they directly engaged with
international current and library
practices to bring good reading directly
to the people
geographically drawing from the u.s
france
england the movement saw the creation of
public libraries as the actualization of
state commitment
to its citizens access to modern
valuable knowledge and expansion of
public services into the countryside
buday presented his book wagons project
as one of vulgarization
and benevolent modernization in this way
the mission
and everyday reality of colonial library
carried this inherently contradictory
ambiguous role
the library reflected state visions of
control modernity and power
yet at the same time the library
advances predominant mission of popular
modern education
allowing for self-directed selection of
reading matter and adapted to demands
for public
access but most importantly my close
study of the biblio buzz
sheds light on the mechanics of book
circulation
and the literary tastes of vietnamese
readers in the provinces i trace the
mechanics of book circulation the book
wagons project and illuminate how
vietnamese readers engage with this
provincial cosmopolitanism
of reading global literature as well as
getting me as new literary forms in the
urban centers of hanoi saigon
i uncovered the vibrant debates amongst
vietnamese intellectuals on the page of
chitton
who called out the failures of colonial
state projects to provide adequate and
equal library access
to enquiry reading materials to the
vietnamese public especially those in
the countryside
these intellectuals propose a distinct
meaning of the public
rooted in a collective consciousness
through the selfless act of building
literary collections specifically in
gupu
this thai national identity to
linguistic identity in guatemala
as the national language of the masses
emphasizing the inherent value of goku
texts
defined vietnamese good reading as a
collective project that involved all
vietnamese
including those in the countryside
beyond the urban centers of hanoi saigon
good reading was not just texts but was
a way of defining modernizing and
uplifting vietnamese leisure practices
spiritual influences and intellectual
nourishment
furthermore good reading and the
preservation of new libraries
contributed to defining a vietnamese
collective cultural identity
and historical temporality from
pre-colonial confucian scholarly
traditions
into the present and into the future
so this excerpt formed a key component
of my fourth chapter of the politics of
good reading and print control
um in the brief remaining time i'm just
going to breeze through
and zoom out a little bit on how this
fits into the larger manuscript project
so in this reading as a book project
the chapters follow a chronological and
thematic structure
the first focusing on builders then the
readers popular libraries print control
the excerpt by red today
and then concluding with decolonization
each chapter considers the relationship
between print control and the public
as well as thinking about the historical
development of libraries as spaces of
reading
education and documentation given this
limited time i'll just briefly discuss
the scope of the first two chapters in
the last chapter
so for example in chapter one i
established the history's vision and key
personnel the four central institutions
examine the book the saigon coach in
china library the hanoi central library
phenom pen library in cambodia and the
directorate of archives and libraries in
china i argue that french colonialism
gave rise to new types of hybrid library
institutions
shaped by the changing politics of the
colonial state and library standards of
print control
i pay particular attention to both high
level labor trained in france and
library sciences and video tech
economy um such as the these short
change administrators in this slide
but i also pay particular attention to
the training of vietnamese laborers
as seen in this slide as a counter
narrative to the first chapter on
builders this chapter
focuses on library users and experiences
in central hanoi
library and coach channel library in
saigon focus on the symbolic
and experienced architecture of the
library this chapter sheds light on the
ways that
library reader bodies were made modern
they're illegible quieted restricted and
monitored
specifically i examined race-based
restrictions to library access
and regulations on popular on proper
behavior to demonstrate the
contradiction
of colonial republican project to
modernize through exclusion and racial
hierarchy
yet by the 20s and 30s vietnamese
students became the majority of library
users and subverted this colonial vision
of the library
an exclusive space for french readers
colonial administrators and scholarly
researchers
i argue that the vietnamese library
users redefined the meaning of modern
public space
by contesting library reading roles
demanding reform and increased access
and reinscribing the actual and symbolic
space of the library through everyday
behavior
i continue on through the chapters to
include with decolonization where i
examine
the decolonization of this elaborate
directorate of archives and libraries
of china as well as the nationalization
of central libraries in the democratic
republic of vietnam and hanoi
the republic of vietnam and saigon i
reveal how decolonization was this
fragmented process
embedded within the logistical movement
of people reading matter
and physically creating spaces as well
as the redefinition of colonial
institutions
in a post-colonial national landscape so
here you have a photograph of
president obinzia inaugurating the
building of this new ambitious national
library project and cultural center in
saigon
um in 1956 and this is actually built on
the former site of the colonial prison
so just to summarize as shown in this
visual through the book
i uncover how the library is at the
center of two intertwined processes
the development of the colonial state
and the public this dynamic history of
the library and colonial imposed colony
of vietnam reveals a hybrid model of
state libraries
which are constantly negotiating between
different information systems
different visions of reading public
access and education
as well as the role of modern state
institutions
so taking a larger step back and
transitioning into q
a i just wanted to share what's been on
my mind as i work through the book
manuscript revisions
and thinking of the library as this
analytical lens
so i'm working on how the library allows
us to understand larger cultural social
literary processes so firstly i'm
i situate the library within reading and
print culture and reveal how libraries
are important sites of cosmopolitan and
textual exchange
as well as understanding the different
historic processes of language learning
and development of french and vietnamese
and in ways that are part of the
landscape of other spaces that are
occurring during this time
bookshops associations clubs temples and
schools but also
libraries are distinct because of the
nature of how
individuals read through self-selection
and self-directed
reading matter as well as public reading
practices
in institutional spaces such as in hanoi
and saigon
libraries for the second point i'm
investigating the role of libraries as
an institution of state documentation of
its subjects
and involving evolving bureaucratic
technical practices
here i seek to contribute new insight
into the field of library science and
information history
where i approach the concept of the
library as both material repository
and a set of technical cultural and
social practices
and lastly how i engage with my archival
newspaper and literary source material
is to provide a cultural history of
urban public spaces and practices of
public reading
specifically that means investigating
and paying attention is
the ways in which these historical
actors are occupying or reclaiming space
in ways that are often not intended by
administrators
thinking about these faces as social or
leisure spaces idle spaces
how individuals seem to constantly be
breaking
breaking rules in the library providing
being noisy being disorderly disrupting
other readers
but also the ways in which the spaces
are gendered and racialized
so i i mean that's um that's just by way
of conclusion which
are the concepts that are evolving in my
mind i very much look forward to q
a as well as just any other questions
about my work
and how it intersects with yours or as
well as just
meeting all of the attendees here thank
you so much
thank you cindy nguyen i will help
moderate the q a session uh so if you
could please
use the raised hand there's already a
couple of questions in the chat
um and then we'll cue up the questions
and if we asked that you know if you
could please um go on camera and and
direct your question
to uh dr nguyen so first up we have uh
dr uh professor haydam hotai um who's
dropped
two questions in here for cindy
so could you please raise your question
uh professor hotay um
well i have quite a few questions
because
your project is really interesting to me
the first one was was the bibliobus
a project meant to counter specifically
the influence of vietnamese journalism
that originated in the cities but was
spread through the provinces
especially after the wave of protest
of 1926 1927
so uh since the bbo bus
project seems to have been launched
in 1928 was there you know
the idea of countering
these protests and the influence of
young franco-anamite trained
protesters in the countryside
so that's my first question and and
i hope that you your work does address
that question
um well firstly thank you so much for
raising that question
um and and your your book on radicalism
definitely has
informed and shapes a lot of my work um
so the short answer
is partially yes
a large significant part of the um
the description specifically from iraq
about um
urban intellectuals and um
even like the coining or the framing of
radicalism and bolshevik ideologies was
very much
a discussion about the specific response
to
to the influence of vietnamese
journalism and the protests in 2627
so i say partially yes because the other
aspect of this project was that it was
a continual large-scale project
involving many actors of course
pierre pasquier and varak but then also
several other several other
culinary administrators and then
the the focus on looking at
um at indonesia as an example
um or the dutch east indies as an
example of how to
how to elaborate and create this system
to counter this
was also kind of intersected and
intersected with those projects but also
predated those protests as well because
there were initiatives
looking at indigenous publishing since
since the early
the specifics of the iraq as as he talks
about
the urban versus rural
tension and sense of threat was
definitely a response to the protests
but i just wanted to situate it's no
longer history of thinking about
indigenous
publishing and forms of substitute
subsidizing um
and and promoting different types of
quote politically safe text and
publishing
and the second part of this of the ways
in which
the project predated and expanded beyond
the specifics
of of these 26 27 protests
is in the role of budae who actually
have proposed the bibliobus
the book wagons project since since 1917
and then later since 1919
so he envisioned forms of at least
distributing
books and the mechanism of how one could
distribute books by drawing from a more
global library approach
of looking at public libraries and book
wagons that was stemming from
from the american library association
sense of like rural libraries projects
that were
developed in america actually since the
turn of the 19th century
um so then there's different initiatives
that are happening at the same time and
i think that's why this chapter was
or this excerpt was so hard to pass
through is that there wasn't one
singular
um justification and the justification
is varied because buday when talking to
pastier of course like
framed his book wagons project as one of
counter prop
like a ways of countering radicalism but
actually in practice
often he he was just discussing the ways
in which how how does one carry out
this in the context of public libraries
and more of a library's
apparatus
okay anybody else wants to raise the
question
because i've got quite a few more
since the biblio bus was
catering to both french and vietnamese
readers um what was the difference in
the materials that were being circulated
with for french for example were they
mostly for entertainment purposes
you know reading for leisure for
vietnamese
was there a more educational propaganda
element to it i mean how would we
know how to differentiate and what
what was the decision-making process for
you know choosing what book to uh
carry to the provinces
thank you so much for that question um
it's a really hard question to
answer given the archival records but
how i understand it was that
often so the reason why i also discussed
the
space limitations in the coaching china
library reading room was that
there were only 44 seats and in
actuality um the reading room was
constantly full
um there were a lot of readers actually
got turned away so this is urban readers
were turned away
and the lending section was incredibly
popular because of the limited space for
readers to actually read in place so
often readers then
borrowed books to read somewhere else
not in the
in the in the actual reading room so my
understanding is that the lending
section is what
then continues to be circulated into the
the provinces so these lending section
collections
the goal of the library was that they
hoped that they would reflect
larger demands and breeder tastes
so i think this is one of the challenges
and i think those who are
in libraries of work in libraries could
um speak to this as well is that
uh libraries have two interwoven um
tensions and i think you also quote uh
references to
which is the initiative to preserve or
to conserve and to circulate
and at times those could work
hand in hand but then if you are um
essentially the more you circulate a
work the more they actually get just the
books get destroyed and
and the more that um you have to put
more attention into actual like
preservation so they're like a two
interval of admissions
um and then and then those that mission
basically underlies the quote-unquote
success of a library is that
the library is extensively used really
well it's circulated really well but it
also preserves and builds a large
collection that reflects
certain collecting practices and the
collecting practices and philosophy of
what to collect
was in principle um very idealistic
reflecting this sense of i guess i was
saying with probably
something that's like has collects all
levels of knowledge as extremely
comprehensive
reflects primarily um the
understanding of what is considered
valuable which
is modeled upon french notions of value
so that's a lot of classics
a lot of works encyclopedias were
collected as well a lot of volumes there
was an attempt
to build large collections of what was
considered like the essential
essential works um at the same time
there were also other
reflections of what was interesting
which is contemporary more
contemporary materials that are
published
in indochina in the actual print sphere
so that could be bulletins that could be
other periodicals
and then the lending section to answer
your question was
then built off of more recent
publications
um and often the collections policy and
what circulated was often
random based on donations based on
cheap editions of what is popular and
thus that is that
becomes cheaper so for example
um you have many editions
of what you see as global best sellers
such as
the count of monte cristo the three
musketeers seen as
kind of pop um
not high class high level literature but
readily available and those end up being
circulated much more readily
and in the biblio buzz because they're
they're cheaper and then there's many
additions of them
all right thanks cindy next we have
a couple hands raised here and um paul
sarno
was the first person that raised his
hand in here so please go ahead
yes i wanted to ask you i saw the those
beautiful colonial buildings that
constituted libraries especially the one
i saw in cambodia
i think it had a date 1924 or so
what what's happened to those buildings
and what's happened to the contents
and if you could start with the
cambodian structure
i'd be interested um thank you so much
paul and this is where
um the cambodian case is one that i feel
very um
uh regretful about mainly because i was
supposed to do field research in the
cambodian library this past summer
um but then that didn't end up happening
amongst many other things
um but from what i understand um is that
that actually that building is now the
the archives the national archives of
cambodia
um and and that is um in that sense it
retained its administrative apparatus
but then
um i mean this is this a lot of this was
like through
conversations with my mentor penny
edwards and the importance of actually
the need to do this type of work
because like during the camera rouge
like this area this building was
um of course not used but then like
had other was occupied for different
reasons from
um and then some of the materials were
either destroyed or
and at times actually destruction of
library materials happens
uh due to neglect not necessarily out of
intention
um so a lot of the materials as many of
you know who
who have done work in southeast asia
because of the humidity because of all
like the bugs and the insects
then get degraded quite quickly
especially because of the paper
so a lot of the materials are not in
great condition
the the cambodian case too is
interesting because
the attempt to build this elaborate
directorate of archives and library
system
in in the five areas of indochina really
was this aspirational aspect where you
know the hanoi central library would be
almost like the equivalent of a national
library and have these
subsequent other headquarters and based
on the different pages the different
countries
um so you have tongkin you have uh
you have a nam you have a coaching china
in the south and then you have laos
and you have campoge and they were
supposed to have like their own
specific headquarters so the camboache
case is one the coaching china library
is another and the north central library
there were attempts to build one boy and
in
laos but then those didn't really pick
up however the cambodia case is
interesting because
there was two parallel major libraries
that developed
the the picture that that beautiful
library that you noted
that actually um uses um more of a
neoclassical style in terms of the
facade
um this library that was supposed to
reflect this administrative colonial
library
in phnom penh but at the same time
suzanne carpenters was working closely
with the buddhist institute
and the royal library which had
kind of predated the administrative
library so there were two libraries that
were
existing one that the administrative
library
which was primarily serving
administrators but kind of lost
a sense of purpose in a sense like it
didn't have a
full public-facing library function it
was more of a reference administrative
almost seemed more like an
archive for administrators and then
the royal library then became the royal
library and buddhist institute was more
as part of the vision to popularize
print and khmer's script and part of
nationalizing
buddhism like that that was an
initiative that like suzanne carpalese
was deeply involved
in and that kind of carried out through
the lens more of cultural
heritage as well as religious
preservation
and and ways of building a vernacular
print sphere in cambodia so then there's
like two
library systems that are very different
in cambodia and i hope to continue to do
my work and expand into projects in
cambodia i just at this moment
that's that's kind of my understanding
of the institutional history
great all right so next next up
we have eric harness and then al lim and
michelle thompson
and also uh dr montanyan
uh cindy wayne has agreed to go a little
bit longer than the 1pm
so we'll keep those questions going so
eric go ahead
first thanks cindy uh this is just so
fascinating such interesting work that
you're doing i just want to congratulate
you on the project overall
and for a nice presentation today too um
when you mentioned about paul buday and
this
idea of um wanting to compete with the
illicit reading material
um you know like the bibliobas and the
library system in general it seems right
um it made me want to know more about
the illicit materials
um and why come already asked the
question i was thinking of it first you
know
like about the journalism but it also
did open up another question i was
thinking about like
well what are all the things that people
are reading that are illicit
and where are they getting them and how
is it circulating
um because i remember when reading about
journalism
one of the things i think in white tom's
book actually you know wing yang min
publishes la close filet but and it has
a certain
you know number of printed copies but of
course people are getting one copy and
like 40 people are reading it or
something like that you know a whole
bunch of people are
and so in a sense it's kind of like a
local library
like they're like a like a kind of
bibliobus
of the people right um and so i'm just
wondering like what are people buying
where are they going what are the
bookstores like in in all this
is there also regulation of what's sold
in the bookstores and all of that
and so a general description of the
reading public and other forms of
circulation
would be really great to hear briefly
thank you eric and i think this is where
um this is very much deeply on my mind
is how do i place the libraries within
this larger ecosystem of print sphere
because of course
individuals are reading widely from all
these different sources from as you
noted like bookstores
um they're passing on the materials um
they're participating in new forms of
like serialized storytelling as well as
different types of journalistic
practices
and i would also like to defer this type
of work to um
with them's tremendous scholarship in
this field as well in terms of thinking
about
journalistic and radicalism as the ways
in which
journalism and different types of kind
of print forms allow for these types of
political organizing as well as forms of
literary expression
yet i think what is interesting about
the of the libraries in this
larger ecosystem is that
it has so there's because of the ways in
which libraries was organized of course
it was
funded by the the governmental state it
had
this deeply archival preservation
mentality of both collecting um what was
considered like works of value but
both based on the french notion of value
and then
also there was a preservation mentality
where
not only was the library operated as the
archives
and as these public libraries but also
operated as the legal deposit
so that means that in principle every
work that was officially
filed for publication in indochina
one copy needed to be filed in the
regional library so if something is
published in saigon it one copy needed
to be filed in the saigon
coaching china library and then one copy
needed to be submitted to the hanoi
central library
into the book depot and then one other
copy needed to be submitted to the legal
deposit in the
national library in paris and this is
where with sean mchale's work where he
analyzed a lot of the legal deposit
works that's how those collections were
built
so in in principle that reflects a
certain
um slice of what was the print
reading production literary journalistic
print production from like the 20s to
the 40s during vietnam
and and mikhail has pointed to like how
it
shows cases a lot of like buddhist
writing material for example
um as well as kind of other
forms of literary um genres uh
satire um and then satire
as well as like fiction and things like
that um
however what's interesting when you look
about the materials that are in the
library so you have this
like the these books of which are
considered quote classics and then you
have these
new forms of indochina published
materials
um new as in um things that are
contemporarily printed
rather than retroactively preserved
and how they differ from what is
basically sold on the streets
um and it's it's not always a blur
like a distinct separation because some
of the most popular works i was saying
make their way
into a librarian too because there's
just so many copies of them they end up
getting added into the library because
of its popularity
however there there was still library
acquisition still went through a process
of somewhat
um of
um indirect censorship which is that
those of which
was not seen as was seen as more
political or
radicalizing and didn't end up in the
library so it's
the other material that end up kind of
in
circulating in bookstores um and
and being re-translated or rewritten and
republished in different editions
um what's interesting as i i have lists
of things of which are books of which
are act
i kind of accidentally end up in the
library which shouldn't have been there
which is really interesting because then
it kind of points to that this regime of
control was much
weaker than we anticipate that which is
often the case
so for example like when london
translated
uh rousseau's social contract and that
circulated in the library for
quite some time and it wasn't it was
debated as to like how
risky or dangerous these works were but
then it kind of
when it was found it was immediately
pulled from the library for example
or there's other like biographies of
chinese nationalists so i think those
are like
that's a quintessential example of of
the
illicit reading of which is circulating
and that also
uh was ended up in the library and then
immediately got flagged as well
there were also initiatives to start
like smaller libraries and
to officially open a library and have it
recognized by the state um you had to
publicly post what the library
even if it was like an association you
had to publicly post what materials were
in there
um and and often so then the clinton
state's trying to police these cases of
like these illicit libraries that are
opening without official registration
and then it's often um lists of of these
either like biographies or
revolutionaries that are circulating
a lot of political tracks um criticisms
explicit criticisms of the state i think
pretty um like
overtly anti-colonial texts and those
libraries immediately tried to
were shut down or police
i realize there's so many questions and
i hope is there a way that i could also
save the chat
so feel free to please also um
there are some questions in the chat and
then um let's see in the
participants uh allen has also raised it
okay go ahead hi thank you so much for
this talk it's super
super fascinating to hear about um i'm
thinking a lot about anderson and
national identity i love the kind of
quote from the
article thinking about civility and the
connection between linguistic and
national identity
i mean i even think that print culture
is that alternative to print capitalism
that chatterjee kind of critiques and so
thinking about
print culture instead of capitalism as a
much more nuanced way to think about
kind of like national identity and
formation um and i'm wondering
how successful were libraries as part of
articulating national identity
so and so much that they do how do we
measure its success especially
i guess with the decolonization chapter
and one way to think about it i love
that you mentioned that wow for example
didn't have a library so
how did they for example articulate
national identity as part of
without a kind of um equivalent library
and
and also thinking about how folks are
like colonial authorities have
different agendas so they're trying to
like um articulate a kind of forceful
kind of like imposition of certain
things versus like borrowers who are
like borrowing books and not necessarily
thinking about national identity in that
way so just
um a lot of i guess a lot of moving
parts and i think to eric's previous
question this idea about
repression like censorship like a focal
intake is like the more you oppress
that doesn't really work in that way so
the more colonial people try to
articulate national identity
that ends up kind of working in very
different ways so i'm just wondering how
do we track kind of that relationship
between nationalism and and libraries
thank you so much al you've asked well
many layers of questions of which i
i hope to be able to answer or
articulate
um in different ways so
as a as a brief answer one question
um that i'm working through right now is
that was actually taken from that this
close analysis of this config
piece is the connection between national
identity and
linguistic identity and this is
something that
underlines so much of my project which
is as i'm tracing the history of the
libraries and thinking to eric's
question even though it comes question
about like what makes the library
kind of different in this larger
ecosystem of other books
is that um the story of the library in
indochina is also the store
like has i would say two other
intertwined stories
which is one on education into one
language
and i would argue that especially
thinking about decolonization
and like let's take the specific
instance of
the in china library um of which
underwent extensive processes of
decolonization in the 50s
and then 54 to 55
with the division of north and south
vietnam
the saigon lord the coach in china
library inherited a third of the french
colonial collections in hanoi
as well as all the staff and the
university of mandalay so there were all
these
colonial institutions that then were
physically logistically moved down to
saigon and then
um saigon the coach and china library
this tiny already cramped library
inherited this collection and it wasn't
just a
like a physical merger but um from
from the fifth actually really earlier
from like 45 to and
especially through 49 the coach in china
library as it was going through this
process decolonization was trying to
articulate how
how do we distinguish ourselves from our
colonial past but also we are inheriting
all of these colonial vestiges french
language materials for example a lot of
material is about
in the archives about the colonial state
so how do we distinguish ourselves
as a as a vietnamese nation and this
process as we understand through
um studying the republic of vietnam and
also through the war was constantly
trying to distinguish itself
from from north vietnam too which is
that the south vietnam
and saigon was was was trying to
articulate itself as this
as this national um cultural heritage
preserver of the legitimate form of all
vietnamese identity
and that and this is where i argue that
the library played a very key part
in this so because it inherited all
these
these colonial materials it also
sought and advocated that this was part
of its mission was that we are
preserving this long history of
all of vietnamese history kind of
symbolized through inheriting
inheriting this collection inheriting
actually
some of the pre-colonial collections
that were also preserved in hanoi
and then additionally looking into the
present and to the future which is that
we needed
as a library needed to advocate and and
transform
language acquisition or like the
acquisition of materials in vietnamese
rather than in french
so there was there was a huge shift um
to to nationalize the library through
the collection of
adamantly searching out and and adding
all vietnamese materials that were
published
newly published in the 50s and 60s as
well as building collections like
chinese language collections as well as
part of the cyclone library
um and and this is where kind of going
back to your question of how does one
articulate because it's national
identity i would argue is
it's very closely intertwined with these
these language policies
as well as
the library um especially this case of
the saigon library
symbolically functioning as this this
fortune like i think the quote said the
fortress of culture
um and our fortress of culture and
heritage that really articulated
a national identity kind of looking
forward but also looking
to its past right so looking to preserve
and create this
kind of streamlined understanding of
what was considered
the legitimate vietnamese national
identity
um i think i'll stop there because i can
keep going with this because it's such a
fascinating way of framing and thank you
so much
for that question okay
great we have michelle thompson next and
then after michelle uh
hi this was just really a wonderful talk
and i was very happy to see it on the
schedule because
it kind of connects with some work i did
earlier on what gets put into an archive
and what does not
i was focusing mainly on gnome i
originally had several questions for you
but you've kind of addressed some of
them in the the question and answer
period
but one thing that hasn't been touched
on but just was just
barely brought up in your your answer
just a minute ago
is connected to staff and there's
a wonderful novel i read a few years ago
and i'm trying to remember the exact
name of it
but it's about a woman in the early 20th
century in the united states who
fought to get to be allowed to be a part
of the staff of a library
in the appalachian mountains who was
delivering books to people on horseback
she literally had
a route like a male route that she
covered like once every couple of weeks
or so it's a really great novel
but you know i thought i would just like
to hear you talk a little bit about the
staff i mean we don't you didn't
really say anything about say gender
makeup of the staff or
you know effects on them effects
of them on their own communities et
cetera i'd like to hear you talk a
little bit about the staff of these
libraries
thank you so much i'm so glad you
brought this question up this was like
the subject of my
one of my other talks where i just
talked about the people
um so so tracing the
the librarians and the staff is was um
a very complicated endeavor because
there was
frequent turnover in low-level staff and
and this would include from like
secretaries copyists typists
um groundskeepers those who are
maintaining security and operations of
the building
but i think what's fascinating about in
a lot of this discussion about the
staff and the personnel and an extensive
record-keeping about the personnel
is that um there was this
there was this uh kind of vibrant
world of librarian low-level staff who
were
were the primary readers of the library
because they worked there
they checked out the books the most and
you see this especially in the cyclone
library
and um it's in these
ex because they'll be um they'll be the
ones who are constantly
they'll be in the book checkout records
and then they actually because they work
in the library and
end up um kind of defying the
restrictions of like only checking out
two books at a time to check out four
for example
um and then in one of my chapters
in in the 1930s there's extensive
discussion about how high-level staff
which are primarily french trained
so at either chart like that's at the
highest level um
of the administrators as like the
director of like for example the saigon
library
and then the lower level librarians um
either
that are french like racially french end
up
coming into the library either working
from like other administrative
governmental offices so if they're not
officially trained in library sciences
then they
are trained in other governmental work
and then you have
um vietnamese um
librarian staff who either have come in
because they've
uh i think in like technically worked in
the
saigon library before and he actually um
was very much involved i think with them
pointed to this too but
involved in other literacy societies
like gupli popular
popularization societies some are
involved as
um as like self-taught linguists um
they're they have like a scholar
bureaucrat type of identity
oh but then the discussion i was talking
about was like in the 30s there was this
rampant extensive discussion between
tension between high-level staff and
low-level staff because there were often
accusations
against low-level staff for stealing
books because they have the most access
to
the library collections so they the
low-level staff were often seen
as suspect from high-level staff
and yeah so that they
and then were dismissed because of other
um tensions or
um kind of um how would i describe this
as kind of disconnects between different
working cultures
uh so for example people showing up late
or people kind of defying the
library roles coming on weekends coming
when it's closed so so
using this space in ways that weren't
intended so these are library staff like
living in this space like
after hours not leaving bringing in
their friends
like things of which were were seen as
as defying a very kind of rigid policy
of library preservation
um or or kind of not being as attentive
to like recording checkouts for example
so i have a lot of these what i see as
these everyday dramas of
library staff um amongst each other but
also tensions between
i have a case for example of a french
reader in the norway central library
who um who
who basically uh physically attacked a
low-level vietnamese
librarian because that librarian would
not bundle up his books that he checked
out
um so then the french administrator or
the french reader patron
um punched the librarian and then the
librarian staff
ended up like reporting this higher
administration but then there was no
kind of type of like consequences for
these this type of
behavior and then that really points to
the racial hierarchies within reading of
these
these of the libraries so i have so many
of these stories michelle i think it's
just
um it's really i'm trying to still make
sense of them just because it
um they're so nuanced and textured um
oh and then the other one i wanted to
mention also is gender
is that the majority of the library
staff are
for male um and low level we're
definitely racially
uh vietnamese but then um
often the discussion about hiring
vietnamese librarians or sorry a female
librarian staff
was um seen as a question
also of it was race and gender questions
because
it costs more to hire a female a french
female
librarian even though and then a lot of
french female librarians ended up being
secretaries but then over time because
of the cost
of paying french administrators or
french
library administrators there was a shift
to train more vietnamese administrators
um uh and then those were ended up often
being male
uh i i think i think i'll end there
because
i could go into another story about
suzanne carpolis but i think i'll
i'll stop here okay and we'll have time
for maybe one
one last question from dr notanya if you
still have questions for us
anyone please drop them in the chat and
we'll share those with her later
this is a question that relates to
michelle
because classification there are a lot
of classification
in the library and some of them are
pre-classification
that will that means acquisition
and then the classification in vietnam
is
very complex through the russian system
and then
through the american system the way
system
and the mach 21 i am
doing a lot of village
documentation and then it it will be
like to bypass all of that and then to
go directly into a computer is uh
to library uh online is uh
probably have to go to along with a
library uh organization
so that they don't have to uh to fire
stuff and then
and if the staff feeling that they are
fired and
they would resist unchanged um that's
that is
one of my questions and i hope to know
that uh
what kind of classification we use in in
the libraries in vietnam and cambodia
thank you so much for this question
definitely
you're pointing to um
the complex information systems that
were used over
the different process over the colonial
and the post-millennial time
so during the colonial period they
followed the technology
the french model of classifications um
and then this this was
thematically organized as well as
so there were two catalogs that were
used one by theme by topic and then one
by author
and then these cataloging systems as the
libraries continue to grow
it it wasn't always updated so like
the author catalog for example was
definitely not updated as much
and it kind of fell apart so often
um the classification system during the
colonial period
was was in principle modeled that way
but then
in practice a lot of the
there were also other aspects of the the
library reading room where
there are books of which were on the
shelves for free perusal
so often these were like marlin
reference encyclopedia as well as
contemporary periodicals that were
available
and then there were separate lending
sections which operated their own
kind of these are collections of about
10 000 works and these would
operate with a a theme
or topic oriented catalog and then
author catalog what's interesting
is by the 50s there was an attempt to
implement the dewey decimal system as
well as well as
to put the saigon library more within
international library standards and then
at the same time as you're you're
mentioning as well is that um the drv
in hanoi the library then was
directly using the russian the biblical
the bbk um
classification system that um
followed like uh well soviet as well as
socialist notions of information
organizing
so i believe i haven't looked at the
classification system in a while but how
i understand it is i think
the first three are like marx lenin
ways of which are like are more about
like socialist forms of knowledge and
information is that right
okay so um and then
um and and now how i understand it too
is that gosh i think the last time the
old card catalogs were still usable in
the hanoi
the national library in hanoi because it
followed the the former cataloging
system from
from the french period then there was a
process
to put them into this the socialist
system
and then after that now it's it's going
through another system of which
it's having issues because of of um
putting it into the catalog
but i think you're right and pointing
out
like the layered ways in which these
classification systems actually
um create this this disarray of the
documentation
um and
and and point to kind of also the
different organizing or intellectual
processes that underlie um
organizing information during these
these different historical periods
thank you thank you very much
thank you for all these wonderful
questions and cindy for answering them
that will wrap it up for for today so
please join me and thank you
uh thanking cindy for this amazing and
fantastic
uh project that she had done
thank you so much what great questions
thank you